we do now have some clue as to what
triggered these sights and sounds on
this Glasgow Street associates of the
perpetrator say he threatened a knife
attack having become mentally fragile
he'd been isolated for three weeks was
suspected coronavirus suraj from yemen
was staying in the park in hotel he told
us he warned staff the night before the
attack the asylum seeker from Sudan was
a risk he said I want to attack with a
knife and he mentioned some name that he
said this they are especially I want to
attack them attack them he starts to
feel everyone against him I said just I
want to warn we don't know what could
happen the reception he said okay I will
take it seriously and they will make the
report and like I don't know what
happened it appears the perpetrator
couldn't cope with living conditions
inside the hotel come and see us inside
anyone everyone waiting the moment to
explode we are in the hotel as a
prisoners I know this is what I'm saying
they don't like it Mears so everyone
like in stress like they cannot go out
because they have time and they cannot
sit on the room because it's everything
in that room they eat they sleep they
wake up they everything in the same
place the condition of police constable
David White has improved no longer
critical but stable he's among six
people still in hospital the authors of
two hotel employees and three asylum
seekers a few hundred yards from the
scene police who were out in force this
wasn't for events of the park in but for
a planned Saturday demonstration that
never materialized police colleagues
paid tribute to those a man they call
the rock he was one of these really
dependable guys who you want to have in
your team he's experienced the officer
of over 13 years most of that time spent
in response policing in glasgow city
centre and you know it is exactly the
type of character who you'd want to be
working with and half by your side
there wasn't just a one warning about
the knife attacker we understand that on
the morning of the incident he had a
telephone consultation with an
immigration lawyer with the help of an
asylum seeker liaison worker that worker
told the lawyer the man was a danger and
the lawyer said he'd contact the Home
Office but shortly after the call ended
the attack took place which begs the
question were the warnings passed on and
were they acted upon the Home Office
says simply it is aware of the incident
the hotel owners and Meers group the
company contracted to house asylum
seekers have expressed sympathy but say
they'll make no further comment because
they say of a live police investigation
one that will look into why this
happened and why it wasn't prevented
James Matthews Sky News Glasgow